I am ready are you ready I are ready to
melt your face off but I don't have a
face that elf melt off your ass
ok so we're playing damned I used to be
emo emo emo or emo so I'm here for emo
wait so I'm starting as the monster then
Oh God all right I've got a torch I can
see the room I don't know if I'm
actually supposed to click anything I
think I just have to run oh I can turn
the torch off as well
it's very pretty awesome I'm coming for
you please what are you doing nothing i
watch her every single move that's a
little creepy
that's a nice skirt you have there oh
it's horrible it's cheap I got it from
Primark we try the majorchord wait is
that me or what
is that you no no where are you the help
I see I see
oh oh I see you now I can only see you
when I'm in my physical form hold on a
minute now I think this a robot or
there's another player in here I can see
him I I can smell you uhh
you smell like blueberry biscuits oh my
favorite oh I can hear you all Jesus
don't knock knock who's there Santa
Claus what do you want a present
it's a bit early gonna get you being a
naughty girl
oh what a hug why do you have no skin oh
[Laughter]
wait did I kill you no that was the
other woman I can the other woman that
[ __ ] died fine I look so sexy I look
like a squid you're a bit new did the
minute that I'd probably prefer if you
covered up what was that I'm sorry all
right I want your dress
that's my shadow's you're scaring me in
the music's picking up I don't like this
do not really
[Laughter]
I can totally open the doors yeah
instead of just clicking on them we've
got a you mind coming for you oh did he
get in if you had a password and I
kicked them there's no more complex
password let's go four one two three
okay wait I mean wow I've got night
vision I sought to be a good friend I've
apparently bat read oh no Batman please
don't kill me I'm a monster will you
call me Bruce all my friends call me
Bruce breath how are you talking to me
right now teller
no not telekinesis which one is it for
what what is that noise oh that is
creepy can i press that oh oh I can also
as a ghost I could probably make noises
around you - oh I need more teeth how
many of you got so far
twelve twelve no you haven't I have one
better be cool I know
no please - one of your friends should
repair piles been pals ed piles oh I
rather be [ __ ] ahead of yourself maybe
one day I'd be a really really good ru
pewds I'm no where are you taking a [ __ ]
cuz I Baba I'm not very good at this
game I know I have found you once here
well I'm just an innocent
okay I've never gentle but you can have
my jacket and zebra that jacket is so
last season my shoes aren't even
matching I have a pink one and a black
one
I'll cover for you there's no way for me
to well let's see second [ __ ] myself
I'm just an innocent man no I don't kid
of God even the right clothes are
probably twice as big as these doors oh
man I can't get free that way oh thank
god trapped yeah okay do you hear this
no no what about this I'll treat you
like one
I love this fish it's like there's you
know singing a fish that you get oh they
have that there's a little song I wrote
don't worry nothing was like the best
thing ever when you were a kid yeah I
got to like it a try was like okay I was
like right okay I'm not that freaked out
anymore but it's still scary yeah but
they hadn't like this thing when you
come near it it'll start doing it right
yeah yeah and I'll go get the sensor
ones yeah the sensor ones you were the
worst yeah all right jump-scare fishes
Bell starts singing oh oh I hate you I
hate you go away what stop scaring me
much why do you look into me I just hold
the sudden got the ability to appear and
then you walked right into me and then I
clicked away because I got scared
yes oh I hear that
stop that I know you were not invited to
play can I have to play oh of course
darling no you can't do that
come on why don't you let me in that
doors no where are you where are you I
don't know okay okay that's good that's
that's my favorite answer all right now
you're back to normal that's good
how do you stop knowing this things you
don't know [ __ ] just listen to the music
it speaks to be man whatever
hey there right yeah
music the language of the soul you know
you don't have a saw that's why I hear
the music and you don't well what was
that did you just do something hey there
princess
oh [ __ ] Oh Oh welcome welcome to in the
little wood today gosh no I starch okay
there we go on the rocks there you go I
said no rice no sorry god dammit oh
maybe come there and kill me
you messed up my drink my first day on
the job that's no excuse
I figured it's easier inhaler
shut up having hay fever before we
started y'all seems to be kicking in
worse than mine
goddamn it why I heard you I'm not
making a sound I don't wanna disturb
your beauty sleep because God knows you
need it but I don't know if Thanks
there's so nice a little nicer I
wouldn't have to kill you all I'm saying
it's a bit of blood she goes a long way
your face is already quite red but just
a little smidge more you don't know
anything about makeup I used to be a
makeup artist you know did you until I
pour acid on my face oh cool that's
different to an arrow in the knee good I
thought that's what you were taking that
no I think that's the first cue you got
because you entered the lobby crawl
alone how we doing
thanks for watching really appreciate it
[Laughter]
[Music]